es muy buenas noches momentos
absolutamente electrificante es los que
acabamos de vivir en este centro de
votación el liceo aplicación en el
centro de santiago donde se daba el
final la votación se avisaba en alto del
cierre de las mesas y se hacía con un
aplauso muy sonoro por parte de todos
los participantes como vemos ya no
quedan aquellas personas simplemente los
vocales de mesa que se encargan ahora
del conteo de la parte más interesante
las cartas ya están echadas como bien
mencionabas el director del servicio
electoral afirmado que se trataría de la
participación más importante desde 2012
el momento en que el voto dejó de ser
obligatorio hemos visto filas históricas
que no se veían en las calles también
impulsadas por el hecho de que la
pandemia ha supuesto que se retrase el
proceso de votación pero la
participación ha sido muy mayoritaria se
han visto muchas colas tanto en santiago
como en otras ciudades de chile como en
el exterior háblanos rápidamente del
voto en el extranjero ya después nos
amplías en el especial
ahorita rápidamente
así es bueno ahora a partir en unos
minutos se va a conocer cuál ha sido el
resultado del voto en el exterior porque
ya han cerrado todos los colegios fuera
de chile lo que hemos sabido a lo largo
de la jornada es que tanto en nueva
zelanda como australia como tokio como
francia en la prueba se imponía
de forma mayoritaria como predecía las
encuestas como también no se optaba por
la convención constitucional mencionar
que como decíamos antes también
comienzan a producirse los primeros
incidentes y manifestaciones en barrio
italia había barricadas hace unos
momentos veremos cómo evolucionan las
cosas en un momento que se tiene que
saber el resultado de las elecciones y a
ver cómo reacciona el pueblo chileno
ante lo que ocurra en las próximas horas